Die monde in unserem sonnensystem sind äußerst faszinierend der mars wird durch seine zum beispiel einen ring wieder saturn bekommen
auf anderen monden ist biologische aktivität und damit leben äußerst wahrscheinlich
und der saturnmond titan hat frappierende
ähnlichkeiten mit der erde die top 7 spannendsten facts zu den mond in unserem sonnensystem gibt es jetzt hier bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir wünschen euch ja nicht nur themen über whatsapp sondern auch über die plattform paefgen vielen dank dafür kommen viele
spannende vorschläge von euch rein dort habt ihr euch ein video zu den mond in unserem sonnensystem gewünscht hier ist es fakt 7
biologische aktivität auf den ice monden des saturns und jupiter
diese entdeckung ja die ist tatsächlich ein indiz für die existenz
außerirdischen lebens hier bei uns im sonnensystem denn an einigen orten im äußeren sonnensystem ist biologische aktivität äußerst wahrscheinlich
cassini die raumsonde hat entdeckt dass das innere von enceladus einer der größten saturnmondes
nicht tiefgefroren ist obwohl der eysmondt mit minus 190 grad eigentlich tief gefroren sein müsste
stattdessen die überraschende entdeckung unter der dicken eisschicht einen
37 kilometer tiefer ozean im mittel tatsächlich
zehnmal tiefer als die ozeane auf der erde der grund dafür sind wurde gezeigten effekte des saturns diese sorgen dafür
dass ein fester kern in dem gewässer durch knetet wird und somit im flüssigen zustand
verbleibt also eben nicht fest ist zudem treten aus rissen in der nähe des südpols
tausende kilometer hohen dampf von denen heraus die analyse der wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler hat ergeben dass diese tatsächlich
alle alle zutaten für leben enthalten
stickstoffverbindung wie methan tätern booten und panzern und salze ein ort also im äußeren sonnensystem an dem leben durchaus
möglich ist genauso übrigens wie die ice monde des jupiters die ebenso tief unter ihrem sociale
verstecken nur der letzte kleine schlüssel fehlt der end wichtige beweis proben von
außerirdischen mikroben doch wahrscheinlich ist das nur noch eine frage der zeit aber wahrscheinlich dann doch von erheblicher zeit fast 6
der maas hat zwei kartoffel monde und das hat konsequenzen
die beiden kleinen knuddeligen trabanten des mars deimos und phobos werden oft auch als
kartoffeln bezeichnet wenn sie haben viele beulen und dellen aufgrund ihrer geringen gravitation haben sie eben keine
ebenmäßige runde form
ausgebildet im vergleich zu unserem erdboden sind sie außerdem super kleinen verbots ist nur 30 kilometer
groß und dem mars sehr nahe von seiner oberfläche ist ja nur 6000 kilometer entfernt deimos ist sogar noch kleiner
20 kilometer also kleiner 20 kilometer zieht aber in etwa
20.000 kilometern entfernung seine bahn wie beide entstanden sind ist noch nicht ganz klar lange dachte man es handelt sich um ein gefangener asteroiden
mittlerweile können sich forschungsteams aber auch vorstellen dass sie durch die kollision eines großen
himmelskörpers mit dem sehr jungen mars entstanden sind so ähnlich wie sich eben auch unser edmund gebildet hat feststehen aber dass phobos auf
katastrophen kurs ist jedes jahr nähert er sich dem mars um etwa zwei meter und wird so in lediglich
20 bis 40 millionen jahren also ist noch ein bisschen hin wohl vom
mars vernichtet werden wahrscheinlich wird er als krümel enden und als diese überreste
dann die werden dann einen ring um den mars bilden fakt fünf saturnmond titan ähnelt der erde
aus wolken regnen flüssige kohlenwasserstoffe und bilden so
seenlandschaften zwar bei - 100
79 grad aber eine gewisse ähnlichkeit zur erde besteht und die bizarren ähnlichkeiten gehen weiter in dieser frostigen
welt existieren auch dünen gebiete wie die raumsonde cassini zeigen konnte mehr als 150 meter hoch und zum teil über hunderte kilometer
lang
wahrscheinlich wohl aus organischen feststoffen oder wasser eis gebildet wie auch auf der erde soll dafür
wind verantwortlich sein auch wenn es in der dichten atmosphäre des mondes wohl eher ein laues
lüftchen ist ein forschungsteam aus tennessee erklärte dies vor drei jahren aber damit dass der wind wohl zweimal während eines autoren jahres umkehrt die
atmosphärischen verhältnisse ändern sich demnach wenn der sonnenschein den
an äquator überschreitet und sich die winde für kurze zeit drehen dann erreichen sie wohl hohe geschwindigkeiten und sind in der lage
diese dünnen zu formen sagt vier
helium 3 als neuer energie lieferant von unserem ehrt mond wir hatten hier schon einmal darüber berichtet forschungsteams weltweit spekulieren auf
brennstoff vom mond für die erde was auf den ersten blick nach science fiction klingt
könnte schon bald realität werden ein möglicher kandidat helium-3
das als treibstoff für
fusionsreaktoren fungieren könnte das isotop soll von robotern auf dem mond abgebaut und dann zur erde transportiert werden
chinas nächste mond mission soll genau das verwirklichen helium-3 ist besteht aus einem neutron
und zwei protonen und ist ein gigantischer energieträger
mit einer tonne des isotops könnte eine 7 millionen einwohner stadt wohl ein jahr lang mit strom versorgt werden
dafür wird das 3 wertige helium benötigt das auf der erde kaum
vorkommen denn es stammt aus dem sonnenwind der den mond aufgrund seines fehlenden
magnetfeldes erreicht so kann sich das helium 3 dort anlagern das
isotop eignet sich hervorragend als brennstoff für die kernfusion bei der fusion mit dem wasserstoff isotop deuterium
beispielsweise entstünde als endprodukt helium 4 der große vorteil ist entsteht keine radioaktive strahlung
einen kleinen nachteil gibt es aber auch zumindest derzeit denn bislang sind noch keine reaktoren entwickelt worden in denen das helium 3
verbrannt werden könnte keiner der reaktoren hat eine positive energiebilanz
denn das große problem ist braucht sehr hohen druck und temperaturen um zwei positiv geladene atomkerne zu verschmelzen und das ist mit heutiger technik
noch wohlgemerkt noch nicht möglich fakt 3 der saturn hat mehr als 70 monde und venus und merkur
keinen wer alle wissen die erde hat einen
mond weiter geht es mit dem mars der zwei monate hat und jupiter und saturn haben sogar jeweils rund 60 bzw
70 merkur und venus dagegen keinen einzigen der mond eines planeten kann auf zwei verschiedene arten und weise entstehen entweder der planet bildet sich zuerst
und fängt später einen kleineren himmelskörper während also jeden 1
hab natürlich umso besser je schwerer der planet ist dass es auch die erklärung dafür warum saturn und jupiter die meisten monde im sonnensystem
besitzen die zweite möglichkeit besteht darin dass planet und sein mund
zusammen entstehen monde bilden sich dann aus staub resten die bei der entstehung eines planeten übrig bleiben fakt 2
die erde und ihre mond bilden eine große
ausnahme nämlich
eigentlich gilt die monde selbst sind viel kleiner als ihre planeten doch die erde ist hier eine ausnahme denn im mond ist viel größer als
er es eigentlich im vergleich zur erde sein dürfte deswegen neben forschungsteams an dass er weder von der erde eingefangen wurde
noch aus staub fressen entstanden ist eine kosmische katastrophe
hat wohl dazu geführt dass die erde einen mond hat kurz nach ihrer entstehung ist sie wohl mit einem himmelskörper
zusammengestoßen der
wahrscheinlich oder sogar bestimmt halb so groß war wie sie selbst eine
unvorstellbare explosion so stark dass die junge erde wieder zusammengeschmolzen ist zumindest zu einem großteil der andere himmelskörper
natürlich auch ein teil der masse hat sich dann in einer umlaufbahn zu einer zweiten kugel geformt
weiter abgekühlt und ist wieder fest geworden genauso wie die größere kugel unsere erde eben fakt eins
kleinster jupitermond auf gefährlichem kollisionskurs
erst anfang juli 2018 wurde bekannt dass ein us forschungsteam
zwölf neue monde des planeten jupiter entdeckt hatte und er somit auf insgesamt
79 monde kommt mehr als jeder andere planet in unserem sonnensystem 11 der neu entdeckt monde sind den
bereits bekannten jupitermonde nämlich doch einer dessen sonderling und das gleich aus mehreren gründen er hat nur einen durchmesser von einem kilometer
und ist somit der kleinste aller bekannten
jupiter trabanten auch seine umlaufbahn ist merz
außergewöhnlicher kreis innerhalb von eineinhalb jahren auf einer hohen und gefährlichen urlaub waren in der nähe der anderen monde einer der beteiligten forscher
scott shepherd bezeichnet die situation als äußerst
instabil eine kollision mit anderen objekten sei demnach sehr wahrscheinlich
also da wird es demnächst
knallen und das werdet ihr natürlich als erste mit hierbei clixoom erfahren und jetzt klicks und werbefrei
keine videos mehr mit eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung vor jeweils einem video im monat ab
bald ist es beim ersten video soweit
werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video draufklicken und bekommt noch exklusive extra videos exklusive live streams wie kommenden dienstag und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien einen riesen dank an all diejenigen die schon dabei sind es werden immer mehr wenn ihr immer garantiert über
aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich übrigens bei whatsapp dann bekommt er den link zum video vor allen anderen
von mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach hier draufklicken und hier darunter geht es weiter mit dafür auch darauf regenwasser eis auf dem mond
bestätigt bis dann
bleibt dran